- Hi cosmic warriors, My name is Aliza.
I am an astrologer, and today we are going
to be looking at the cosmic compatibility
between Justin Bieber, Hailey
Baldwin, and Selena Gomez.
(upbeat music)
What I do every day is
I look at the stars.
The natal chart is a snapshot
of the sky at the exact moment of birth.
You can look at a natal
chart to figure out
future events, past events,
everything you need about somebody
is embedded within your chart.
Okay, so first and
foremost, I just want to
set the record straight
that I am not a Biebling.
Is that what it's called?
I respect Justin Bieber, I
respect all of these people,
but I do not follow them,
I do not have preferences,
and I am not rooting for any
one person in particular.
So, first and foremost,
we have Justin Bieber.
He is a
Pisces sun with a Libra moon,
and even though we don't
know the exact time of birth,
we have enough information to deduce
that he must be a Scorpio rising.
Justin Bieber is really looking
to find clarity, to find wisdom,
and to transcend this
earthly plane that we're in,
like so many of us, and especially Pisces,
which is such an ethereal sign.
So this means that really
what is going on in his chart
is a lot, a lot of water energy.
So Justin Bieber is probably psychic.
So there is a cosmic connection
between these two people.
The first thing that jumps out to me
when I'm looking at these
charts side by side,
is that their moons are
in complete opposition.
It's really going now.
Their moons are in complete opposition.
These two people are here
to teach each other lessons.
Justin Bieber hates being alone.
You have heard it here first.
Interestingly Hailey Baldwin
with her moon, an Aries,
the opposite sign of
Libra, is the sign of me.
So Libra is we, and Aries is me.
And when these two come together
they're teaching the
other about themselves.
They are having fun.
They're having the best time
of their lives together,
they're having a blast,
they're posting about getting
engaged, they are going out,
and they're probably gonna
go on like a fun island trip.
Justin's Uranus is in
Capricorn at 24 degrees,
and her Neptune, which
is fantasy, and illusion,
and actually the entertainment industry
is at 25 degrees in Capricorn.
Uranus is shocking things,
things that come out of nowhere.
Neptune is the entertainment industry.
So when we put these together,
yeah we're gonna make some big splash,
and we're gonna make
some big public statement
that is gonna rock everybody's world,
that nobody saw coming,
and it's kind of, like,
a little bit of a f*** you to the man.
Regarding Selena,
so I do think that there really
is an interesting relationship
between Selena Gomez and
Justin Bieber, 100 percent,
Their sun, which is their ego,
their essence, their sense of self,
fall in the eighth house,
and the eighth house is
the area of the chart
linked to sex, death, and transformation.
Both of these people, Selena
to Justin and Justin to Selena,
are really, really karmic.
It's a really karmic connection
that these two people have,
and have had with each
other for a very long time.
I think in that she also accepts the fact
that this is a relationship
that maybe she needs to let go of
in order for her to reach
her fullest potential.
So final thoughts on these charts,
after spending a little time
with them and looking at them,
I think that there is a
really important purpose
between Justin and Hailey
and their engagement,
and what this symbolizes to them.
While engagement may
mean something to you,
it may mean something totally different
to Justin and Hailey.
But definitely anticipating that by
October 2018 we are going to see them
in the public eye again
in a very, very big way.
In terms of Selena, she is a goddess.
She is absolutely fine,
and I honestly think
that she wishes them well.
Ultimately she's on her own path too,
and everyone's gonna be great.
Thank you all so much for watching,
my name is Aliza,
I am the author of The
Mixology of Astrology,
and I will see you next time in the stars.
(upbeat music)